travis when did you move to los angeles
and why
2016 uh august 26th yeah i've only been
out here a couple years
wow okay um and again because i wanted
to get into television writing like you
can write features anywhere but if you
want to do tv you got to be out here
where the rooms are
um you know they might film in other
places you know like vancouver is a big
place to film because of all the film
incentives that they have you know like
tax budget
tax breaks and stuff like that but the
rooms are all still out here in los
angeles there's a couple in new york but
mostly out here
so since i wanted to do tv writing i
kind of had to be where the rooms are
and moved out here
to do that and what were you doing prior
to 2016 what was life like
for travis so i moved here from virginia
beach um
so i like i'm originally from michigan i
moved from michigan
to virginia in 2011 uh to be a massage
therapist
yeah i've done a lot of jobs in my life
so i'm moving there to be a massage
therapist did that for a few years kind
of got burned out on it
um and then was working as a uh
a dispatcher for an alarm security
company oh but also yeah
and but still writing on on the side you
know for for writing
so like i got hired when i was working
there got hired to write eight episodes
of a sci-fi series in the uk
that to the best of my knowledge still
has not come out and that was
you know years ago now um and
wrote like a bunch of different features
for like independent producers
all around the country like a lot of
people when i tell them out here that oh
yeah i was getting
jobs in virginia and they're like oh
well that's different out here no i was
writing for hollywood
producers like low budget hollywood
producers from virginia
uh you know so i was still doing the
writing but
doing all these other odd jobs on the
side as well
and did you fly out or drive i drove uh
right yeah so i actually
took me a couple days to get here
because i drove from virginia beach i
drove up to michigan so i could see my
parents because i hadn't seen them in a
couple years since i had moved
um i still haven't seen my sister even
since when was the last time i saw naoka
uh like 2011 i think like i think it was
like the first year i had moved away and
i came back for christmas that's the
last time i even see my sister
so hopefully she comes out to my wedding
later this year
do you want to address do you want to
give her an invitation right now or well
she she's okay
she's she's one of my best men basically
she's
nice i have groom's people you know
there we go yeah so
i had to have my sister in there but
yeah so i moved so when i was moving i
drove up to michigan
spent like a day or so with my parents
uh and then
drove the rest away out here like i made
a couple stops like overnight because
it's
too far to drive in one thing so i think
i stopped in kansas city and then a
second stop in phoenix where my cousin
lives and
uh hung out with him for a day and then
got out here and then had my first
hollywood meeting like two days after i
arrived so
with the manager it didn't go so well uh
unfortunately um
but you know his first meeting can't
really expect because i didn't know what
to do at my first meeting all my
experience before then was either
meetings on the phone or or via email
you know so
i feel like i babbled like i did like
i'm doing now well i'm actually
maybe just leaving out names to protect
the innocent or not so innocent
what what was what do you think went
poorly about it
um the fact that i didn't really know
how to conduct a meeting
uh first so i was kind of going off on
various tangents on all my various
projects uh
it was the manager so they want to know
like your best thing and what you do
um not everything you've ever written
kind of thing you know and so i was
sitting there going
oh i've written this horror and i've
written this sci-fi and i've written
this thing for tv and movies and blah
blah
and it's like when you get done so many
things you don't want to mention all
those things because nobody cares at a
certain point you know like
um especially when things aren't being
produced so
uh that's my the one advice i probably
break my own advice
often enough and stuff is don't tell
everyone when you're when you're having
a meeting with the manager don't tell
them every single thing up front you
know it's only like a date
yeah oh i've had some bad days where
i've done that for sure
um yeah okay so like you're going on so
like
going off way too f onto way too many
tangents telling wait like over
sharing like crazy um did not go well
and then
not really knowing i guess like where
you fit
in the industry um is kind of hurtful uh
because you want like there's so many
people out there who want to do all
these other things
you go to like a networking thing and
you're people who are like 8 000
hyphenates oh i'm a writer director
producer
art director blah blah you know or
people who are like oh yeah i can write
everything
i write drama and horror and comedy no
you don't
you write like one thing really well you
might be interested in writing those
things you might even have scripts and
other things but
there's no way you write equally well
across the board in every genre
it's just not happening do you think it
was just being eager
and maybe you know the industry hadn't
beaten you down and so you didn't know
and you were just being innocently eager
um possibly
um but i feel like again that kind of
goes with like a naivete about how the
industry really works
um you know having again not having had
any in-person time like face-to-face
with with hollywood industry
folks it was just you know sending out
an email or being on the phone with
somebody
um reading screenwriting books and stuff
you know they usually tell you like
how to write the script scripts there's
not really a lot of business
oriented books out there so um
you don't really learn how to conduct a
meeting very well unless you're actually
doing it because
you can have all the theory on it you
want but until you're face to face with
somebody
uh knowing how you're gonna behave with
them totally different
when you finished that meeting did you
already have an intuition about this
didn't go well yeah
kind of um kind of like when you go for
an interview for a job you kind of have
an idea if it went well or not
right but you know
i've had meetings with producers too
where i have no clue how it went when i
walked out because they're so straight
faced
they're not giving anything away and
then like so you could think you did
terribly and then they call you the next
day
want you to come and write their thing
you know so it's hard to gauge usually
but i feel like in that particular case
i kind of
knew that it wasn't going to go the way
i wanted it to go when i walked out so
when they start when they start checking
their watch or their phone and stuff
part way through the meeting you know
that's not a
good thing with the phone thing it might
just be
typical etiquette these days with with
people you know
being glued to their communication but
when you left that meeting what was your
feeling about
being in l.a you'd been here what two
days yeah i had gotten here
sunday night of that week and the
interview the meeting with her was
tuesday morning so yeah like a day and a
half maybe
um i know when i was moving i hear
people were telling me about like
all the traffic and i'm gonna be sitting
on the freeway forever but i'm
against i'm originally from detroit area
like nobody lives in detroit but people
work there you know so it's like
the commute that way so the only
difference is here it's much shorter
distances
in the traffic so um but the weather is
fantastic i
hate snow which is why i wanted to get
out of michigan to begin with and the
snow followed me to virginia because
a friend of mine who lives in virginia
where i moved to told me oh there's no
snow here ever
like first year i moved there blizzard
of like 13 inches
every year i lived there it was at least
eight inches
out here i have not a single day of snow
it's fantastic i love it
so then you you still had your hopes up
or did you oh absolutely
i you i'm not one to easily get down
especially knowing
like i said how hard it is anyway so um
it's just
sticking notch on the belt kind of thing
oh here's another no okay
moving on let's you can't just let the
nose get to you otherwise like
you will drop out of this business like
immediately like even
like spielberg is even getting no's and
he's steven spielberg you know
you're always going to get the nose and
because you can't uh you can't appease
everybody's tastes and everything you
know so like i've had
i've had scripts that in one contest
doesn't even get the quarterfinals
another one will be a semi-finalist
give them a top two or something like
that you have people when
having getting notes on scripts where
one person will love this scene and talk
about how amazing the scene is the next
person's like oh this is a terrible
scene it needs to change
and it's like they're talking about the
exact same thing and one person loves it
one person hates it so
you know you can't really base
your feelings on the industry on what
one person's opinion is
you know you kind of gotta keep keep
going and keep trying and getting your
stuff out there
you